advertising was so much fun because we
were the first
company to use rock and roll music
now you can imagine at san francisco
rock and roll
bill graham auditorium i got to work
with the jefferson airplane and the
sopwith camel and sly in the family
stone
i mean i thought i died and went to
heaven i was having so much fun
[Music]
tomcaston thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great it's great to be with you
michael i
am so excited to uh you know take
nuggets
out of your 34 wonderful years at levi's
as a senior executive
and president of youth wear apparel and
men's jeans and women's clothing and
then all sorts of
different extraordinary things that you
know i take for granted when i
when i walk into the store and i believe
that i'm wearing levi's jeans right now
so i'm extremely excited to hear about
what it means to be a senior executive
at such a company
and a little bit about retail a little
bit about fashion and then do this you
know drastic transition more to public
service being a two-time mayor
of hillsborough as well as uh serving on
a
numerous school public
organizations boards of jewish
organizations so tom
um i rambled enough take it away who are
you
and how do you get started with levis uh
it's uh
uh interesting story it goes back quite
a few years uh
i was in grad school getting my uh mba
and in one of my classes the professor
would bring in ceos
of existing companies and one of the
ceos that came in
was walter house jr who was the ceo of
levi strauss and company
wow he was the only ceo that we had that
actually talked about
values not just about you know profit
and
revenue i love it and so i went up to
him afterwards and i i made that
observation with him i said you know
you're the only one
who's talked about the importance of
values and culture in an organization
and he handed me his business card and
he said see me when you graduate
um and so i did uh i
ended up joining levi's i was
interviewing with three different
companies but
levi's it was always sort of in my heart
uh
san francisco company i don't have to
move anywhere
consumer product which is what i knew i
wanted to get into
because i'm fascinated by consumer
behavior
and so that's where the uh the love
began
if you will and i joined them before
they had any kind of training program
but what they did is they rotated me
through various departments
and i sort of fell in love with uh
product development
and so uh not that i studied it in
school i never had a class on product
development but
um when i joined levi's they had just
reached a hundred million dollars
and i thought oh my gosh i'm joining
such a big a big company
and i had interviewed with ford motor
company and uh
a tech company and uh
i i decided that i wanted to do this it
was right up my alley my first job was
in market research which is a great
a place to start because it gives you an
overview of the company and the markets
the constructor and uh i
then did a stint in advertising
advertising was so much fun because we
were the first
company to use rock and roll music
now you can imagine at san francisco
rock and roll
bill graham auditorium i got to work
with the jefferson airplane and the
sopwith camel and sly in the family
stone
i mean i thought i died and went to
heaven i was having so much fun
amazing from there i went into product
development and really kind of found my
niche
and uh rose through the rank so to speak
uh somebody once said of my career levi
said tom could never hold a job because
he changed every two years
and um so um i
uh rose up through the ranks uh
my first the division president job at a
very young age i might have i thought
like
wow i'm a division president you know
i'm still wet behind the ears
was in the youth wear business um which
is
what a great training ground really uh
we were not particularly dominant in in
uh
kidswear but it was good training for me
and then i became president of the
biggest division
in the company uh the genes division and
uh yes i took that to its first billion
dollars and i thought
really a billion dollar business i can't
believe this and these were fully
integrated uh businesses so i had
production
manufacturing sales uh finance
everything um uh it was like running a
company
and okay tom i have to stop you there
because first of all
i'm bowing down you know i think that
you know for any
anytime i get to speak to somebody who
grew up who grew a business to a billion
dollar business
putting even aside that it's a business
that probably every person in the world
knows the brandon can associate the
quality
and the youthfulness with the brand but
talk to me about it about what it's like
to
to take ownership of of levi's jeans you
know one of the most popular
pop pro probably popular clothing items
in the world levi's jeans
and what is some of the thought process
that you bring into this how do you
innovate
within fashion and retail well the first
thought is
don't screw it up it was
you know it was a tremendous
responsibility and i did feel the weight
of responsibility because basically it
was the engine that drove the company
um in having other jobs at levi's i
learned the importance of listening to
the consumer
and the customer now what's the
difference the consumer is the person
who actually buys the product in the
store and wears it
the customer is the retail store you
have to please the customer
in order to get your product in front of
the consumer and then you better pay a
lot of attention to the consumer
fortunately in my uh role in market
research i did a lot of research among
young people because that was our
primary market so i was at the bill
graham auditorium every saturday
talking to young kids who are wearing
jeans and so i'm amazing
translate that back into uh when i was
running
uh the uh the men's product
and um it's just really
constantly keeping your ear to the
market listening to the customer
listening to the consumer watching what
your competitors are doing
and looking for those uh drivers
that affect trains color so i used to go
to paint stores and look at the new
colored chips
i used to go to real gyms to see what
was being shown
going to art galleries you have to look
very broadly
to understand what are the trends that
are driving consumer taste
and behavior when you start to
understand that you can begin
to project and predict not 100
all the time but more successful than
not
um but it's even more responsibility
than that because you're both
assimilating to existing trends that
you're observing but you are creating a
trend yourself
levi's genes is a is a movement right
it's a trend
it's a community it's a it's a stamp
that that people want to adhere to so
it's not just the responsibility of
of meeting the expectations but it's
also creating those expectations
for the next generation right right but
also
um keeping the quality high uh
we were the number one brand by far
we're an iconic brand uh
it's it's often used generically you
know hey i've got my levi's on and when
you look at the product they're not
wearing
levi's jeans we protected our trademark
and our ipv
very very carefully there's a wonderful
picture
when the berlin wall fell of a
large number of young people teenagers
people
and kids in their 20s sitting on top of
the berlin wall
every one of them wearing jeans now they
probably weren't all levi's jeans but we
were well represented
uh on that and it was loved
in um uh the eastern countries and
russia etc why it stood for independence
it stood
for uh the pioneering spirit it it stood
for
uh being able to be yourself
and uh so it was a highly coveted
product
all over the world um when i moved over
to women's wear which was an interesting
story that we don't have time for
but it became even more important to
understand the consumer because
women are very uh
focused on fashion and uh they change
their mind
often but they know exactly what they
want men uh i want a pair of jeans this
fits okay i walk out the store women are
very
about um the way the garment fits
and so i had to hone even further
um my instincts for listening to the
customer the retailer
and and the consumer and really
understanding
the women's brands and the women's
business there are
far more brands in women's wear than
there are in menswear
so that was a very exciting uh time for
me
when i took over that division uh it was
mostly men and i thought why are men
so heavily involved in this and so i
started bringing in more women and at
the end our division had like five men
and 80 women
uh in the in the uh headquarters
but it it helped me understand how to
move
quickly because the women's business is
a much faster business
the products change much more frequently
and i have to admit i made more mistakes
uh or we made more mistakes because um
you can't be 100 perfect in terms of
reading
uh the uh fashion trends that are that
are taking place
um so tom were you always interested in
fashion
growing up during your mba yes i knew i
wanted to go into a consumer business
and i actually thought about retail
i thought about going to new york and
working for one of the large department
stores
i had a professor who was really pushing
me toward that uh
but i had grown up in levi's one of my
dad's best friends was a levi's salesman
um and so when i had the opportunity to
join levi's i knew exactly that's where
i wanted to go
sorry ford motor company but that's the
way it worked out
and it was a fabulous career because i
never got bored we were growing so fast
that i always had these opportunities to
move into different
venues and different lines of business
uh when i became
executive vice president of new business
development now i was talking about
acquisitions and licensing um and that
broadened again my
my perspective one of the jobs i ended
up doing was
running information technology for the
united states
why because they wanted a business
person to run technology because
that they felt that it was important
that whoever is running technology
actually knew something about the
business and that was a lot of fun
because i had to learn a lot
very rapidly so um i i remember a
comment that
one of my senior managers made
she came in and she closed the door and
she said tom we're really glad you're
here
uh and i said well i'm thrilled to be
here i know i have a lot to learn she
says tom
don't worry about the technology that's
why we're here we need you to teach us
the business
and to understand how the apparel
business works
which was what i did and which was a lot
of fun
tom i'd love to hear you know obviously
we can't you know there's still
34 years of experience um in the retail
apparel business
into you know a few minutes but i'd love
to hear some of your nuggets
as to how you approached understanding
consumer behavior so we talked about
you know understanding trends understand
go you know you're going into the
museums and the paint shops and seeing
how do you actually then think more
globally about okay
you know making a change to the levees
brand that's a big deal right
you're deciding on on how it's it's a
huge deal
what is this what does that thinking
process look like how do you validate
a pos a potential change in the design
process
you know before you branch it out to you
know millions of people
so this probably should not come as any
surprise
first of all we are an international
brand so i did travel the world
and i went to some of the leading
apparel shows
like uh in cologne germany which was one
of the largest shows
uh just to see what uh other brands were
doing
in other countries i think the the most
important
source for me for information was the
sales clerk
on the floor of a retail store a lot of
my colleagues would go visit the
president of the store or the general
merchandise manager i wanted to talk to
the people who interfaced with the
consumer
i wanted to find out what did they like
and what didn't they like
and it wasn't just about the levi's
brand tell me about these other brands
which is your best-selling brand which
product in that brand is best
is the the biggest seller because these
are the people that really know right
these are the ones
who here this brand doesn't fit me or i
don't like this color or this fabric is
too heavy
so these are the people that really
provide the stories you can read a lot
there's a lot of
information trade press etc
but there's no substitution for actually
being
on the front writings if you will and so
it's taking in a lot of information and
synthesizing that information
and looking for the strategic nuggets
that come out of that
right no no that makes a lot of sense
and tom i want to make sure we have
enough time to talk about
the second part of of your fascinating
journey which is really public service
and i have to understand that for both
the motivation but also
the job itself being a mayor of of a
city
in california serving on the board of
various organizations why do that why
leave 34 years as a as an executive at
levi's
and then transition to being a mayor so
another interesting story um while i was
at levi's i
i did a lot of volunteer work outside of
the company
and one of the jobs that i had was
president of the hillsborough schools
foundation it was a
foundation that raised money to
supplement the
uh finances of our schools
because we weren't getting enough money
from the state california has always had
a little
uh difficulty giving enough money to
education
when i retired i got a call about three
months later
from uh somebody who had served on the
school board
uh while i was president of the
foundation and who was now on the city
council and said i'd like to talk to you
we had lunch
he said there's going to be an opening
on the city council we think
you should um run for city council
i was a little surprised but i i came
home and i talked about it
with my wife and i decided well let me
go to a couple of city council meetings
and see what goes on there
and i did and then i talked to the
person uh the woman who was
leaving the position and i decided okay
my wife's a teacher she knew she was
going to teach at least four more years
that's interesting that's what the term
is four years so i thought
well i've worked in the uh private
sector
i've also worked in the non-profit
sector let me work in the third
sector of the economy which is public
service
so i decided to run and got elected
and uh joined the city council and then
and then as you said
uh became a two-time mayor uh it was a
fascinating experience
um the the biggest thing i learned is
that it moves at a glacial pace uh i
couldn't believe how
slowly things happen and uh in the
beginning it caused me uh some
difficulty because i kept pushing and i
wanted to move faster
but eventually you get into the rhythm
of a business
and you begin to understand the
complexities and
but you could bring a lot of what you
learned
from the for-profit world into
the private sector in fact they're
hungry for it
and uh so i was on a number of county
boards and regional boards i chaired a
couple of them
and uh as you you said i uh i was
elected mayor twice
and it was a very interesting experience
um and one that i enjoyed for for 12
years but
then amazing how do you deal with the
glacial pace in comparison to
you know being a president of you know
divisions within levi's where i'm sure
that
you know things might not move as
quickly as in a startup but they're
still moving quick enough to adapt to
the market and the market is dictating
the speed
how do you adapt you know even
emotionally to to be a leader
in a glacial pace you know environment
well it's interesting because
at levi's um i looked at the women's
wear business as a startup
i mean i really had to restart that
business it was it was
hemorrhaging money like crazy and uh in
a relatively
uh short time i was able to make it the
third biggest profit contributor into
the
into the company i i say i but it wasn't
i it was we
all the time it was we um hiring good
people
uh is the key to success i think in in
any place so i should be using we
not i um and uh
it it requires that you have to adapt
and adjust to the timing you can push it
a little
you can have an influence but because of
laws and various requirements coming out
of the state or federal government
there's some things some steps
that could not be short-circuited and
you had to accept that so you had to
look at
where can i have the greatest influence
where can i help people make progress
and attack those areas and uh
so and you adjust your own you calibrate
yourself
uh so that you uh don't get frustrated
along the way in in public service
everybody has a voice
and you have to listen to all the voices
don't necessarily have to do
what they say but you have to listen to
them and they have to feel listened to
and then the importance of building
consensus
very very important in government work
uh if you want to get anything done
100 tom i want to thank you for being so
generous and so thoughtful during these
20 minutes i think we're gonna have to
do um another at least an episode or two
to cover you know some of the fun
stories that we didn't get a chance to
talk about
and and i think that it's just
remarkable about both i think
you know getting a chance to speak to
somebody who's ha who's had the senior
executive role for so many years that at
such a fascinating company
and i know so little about retail and
apparel and fashion that i'm excited to
learn more
from your journey but but i appreciate
you taking the time to do this
and before we leave i have to ask you
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself
three words um okay i'll give you the
three
c's all right curious
continuous learning
and compassionate i love that
tom thank you very very much toda and
stay safe and stay healthy you too
michael i've really enjoyed this
have a good uh holiday and let's
all look forward to a much better 2021